هدير مياه سد نوفا كخوفكا المنهار لا يزال
مسموعا في اوكرانيا وسط اتهامات متبادله
بين موسكو وكيف والقلق يتزايد من تحول
الاراضي الزراعيه الى صحاري المياه تحولت
منذ سنوات الى سلاح في تكتيكات الحرب ليس
فقط في اوكرانيا
ففي عام
خلال الحرب الصينيه اليابانيه الثانيه
قامت الصين بهدم السدود الترابيه لدى
النهر الاصفر لاغراق المنطقه باسرها بغيت
شل تقدم الجيش الياباني وفي عام
استهدف سلاح الجو البريطاني مجموعه من
السدود الالمانيه الواقعه في وادي الروره
باسم عمليه العقاب في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه قصف
الجيش الامريكي السدود في كوريا الشماليه
وفيتنام الشماليه لتدمير البنيه التحتيه
للكهرباء والري للحكومات الشيوعيه اما في
عام 2014
فقد كان لتدمير تنظيم داعش سد الموصل اثار
كارثيه ومدمره في عموم العراق
اذا المياه سلاح تكتيكي حربي قديم متجدد
لطالما تم استخدامه في الحروب لمواجهه
العدو لكن في عام
حضرت اتفاقيات جينيف على وجه التحديد
استهداف البنيه التحتيه للمياه في زمن
الحرب لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات